[Musique]
la pratique ancestrale du T en Chine
consiste à rester cloîré durant un mois
à la suite de la naissance d'un enfant
les préceptes à suivre hérités de la
médecine traditionnelle chinoise
commande notamment de ne pas se laver de
ne pas se brosser les dents ni de manger
ou boire d'aliments froids cette
tradition connaît un nouvel élan dans le
pays notamment auprès de femmes de la
classe aisée chinoise les familles qui
en ont les moyens ne confient plus les
soins prodigués à la nouvelle mère aux
tantes ou à la grand-mère mais une aide
à domicile une huée SW qu'on embuche
pour le mois pour environ 2000 dollars
celle-ci apporte son aide par exemple
pour les soins du bébé les repas et
offre des conseils sur l'allaitement le
pays voit aussi apparaître des centres
de maternité se spécialisant dans le T
le site Dian ping sort de Trip Advisor
chinois listerait une centaine de ces
centres pour la ville de Shanghai
uniquement pour 10 20 ou 30000 dollars
par mois les nouvelles mamans fortunées
ont accès à des cours de yoga des
traiteurs des nounous qui veillent sur
leurs bébés et des chambres d'hôtel
luxueuse